okay i think we're live
i
this is michael balter with science
welcome to science live today as you can
have hopefully seen from all the tweets
and social media and the publicity we're
going to be discussing something called
the anthropocene or the age of man
and this is a proposed new geological
epoch
that
many geologists and
climate scientists
have proposed that we have now entered
into
and that would follow on from the
current holocene which is basically the
geological epic that began about 11 700
years ago
and basically corresponds with the end
of the last ice age
my guest today and we're going to talk
about not only
does it exist should it exist
and should it be
officially designated but also
when it should start if it should start
so my guests today are philip gibbert
who's a geologist at the university of
cambridge in the uk
phillip is actually a member of the
working group on the anthropocene that
is looking at the issue of whether we
should have a designation of an official
new
uh epoch and by the way i should mention
that we reason we call it the age of man
and the reason this is even being
considered
is because it's assumed to correspond
with human activity on the planet not
only global warming but all of the other
ways that humans have transformed the
planet and philip is very directly
involved in these issues although he has
an interesting perspective that he's
going to share with us
also with us is bruce smith
at the smithsonian's
institutions national museum of natural
history uh bruce is the curator of north
american archaeology there
he's an expert in the domestication and
origins of agriculture domestication of
plants
in particular and the origins of
agriculture
in
north and south america
and more recently has been
very
active and sort of theoretical issues
concerning the way that prehistoric
humans began to change the environment
something uh which he and his colleagues
call human niche construction
so
welcome gentlemen and i hope uh you can
hear me and that uh our viewers can see
both of us
um philip i'd like to uh
start with you first
um and i'm going to ask you both some
brief questions and then we will go to
the comments which are i i think going
to start coming in quite soon
uh
on our uh comments page
from viewers who will uh
be having a lot to ask you i'm sure
so philip let me start with you
um
you have an interesting perspective on
this because although you're a member of
the working group on the anthropocene
you've taken the position uh most
recently in a short article or sort of
debate in the french science magazine la
riches
that you think that we should not
officially designate the anthropocene at
least not not at this point and the
interesting thing about your position
though is that
you seem to agree and i think you said
to me in an email uh some about a week
or so ago
that
if we did start the anthropocene that we
may well want to start it back at the
beginning of the holocene or started a
long time ago but this is not really the
right time to be doing it and you had
several interesting um reasons for that
i wonder if you could just very briefly
share those with the viewers
yeah sure i'm um thank you michael i'm
not
sure precisely what we discussed but uh
i i um
and we i should
you know be honest that i'm coming at
this thing as a geologist and
um
my role in this has been the um
division of geological time effectively
and uh
really we're concerned with the division
of geological time
in the in the quaternary as a whole
which of which the present time
excuse me remains to be apart so the
quaternary extends right to the present
day irrespective of whether we um define
um an anthropocene or not we still
remain in a quaternary and that's
because geological time is divided in a
sort of hierarchical fashion into um
large-scale units
which we call
periods or systems
and and then into progressively smaller
units which uh you know provide a kind
of hierarchical division and um
the last two and a half million years is
divided into is called the quaternary
and it's that's that's called a a period
or a system
uh depending on whether it's
geochronology or um um
chronostratigraphy which is the the
means by which we divide time in geology
and then at a lower hierarchical level
the next level down we have um what you
mentioned at the beginning in your
introduction epochs and series and the
epoch um for example the pleistocene is
one epoch the uh holocene is another
epoch and uh these are um
these units are still quite large scale
units but they define um they defined a
period of the of the uh
and the pleistocene began at two and a
half million at the same time as the
quaternary um but it ended as you said
in your introduction at 11.7
000 uh years ago yes eleven thousand
seven hundred if you prefer um and
that's when the period called the
holocene began
and the holocene is uh
has defined as such
because it represents
the present period of relatively warm
climate um which we are living in
and uh
the holocene is is what we call an
interglacial in the in the quaternary
the quaternary has uh is characterized
by i say
is yes but those ice ages are punctuated
by
intervening warm periods which we call
interglacial periods um and they are
similar to the present day that is with
relatively high sea level relatively
limited glaciation limited just to the
high latitudes or high mountain areas
and um
relatively uh warm conditions
throughout the world um glaciations of
course are the opposite now the holocene
this this period that began eleven
thousand seven hundred years ago is the
uh is also an interglacial but
you might then reasonably ask why isn't
it included in the plasticine
well the reason it's not included in the
pleistocene is because
it's the period that of course is
characterized by the rise of um homo
sapiens and is and uh
the development of of of modern human uh
populations and civilizations
um and for that reason alone uh the
holocene has been separated off
uh
therefore uh we are in a a a rather
interesting position with the concept of
uh which has just been introduced of
course uh about 10 years ago by
by um
paul cruzen and uh and his colleague uh
again
um uh stronger
about the this this concept of an
anthropocene because if
if if we wish to if we wish to create an
in a period
dominated by humans that is a sort of
anthropocene period in which humans have
been operating and which have which they
as it were grown to such large numbers
that we are now influencing uh
most if not all natural systems um we
are using a criterion that is huge the
presence to humans
and their activities
um
twice because we used it to define the
holocene and now we're using it to
define the anthropocene
the question from a geological point of
view is do we need this anthropocene
division um what is its function
and
why is it different from the holocene
so i hope that
provides a basis for our discussion this
evening i mean
in the discussions which which we've
which have been held so far
uh in the international arena a great
deal has been made of human
activity and quite rightly of course
but that has to be seen in the context
of a longer geological time scale if we
are to define
some formal uh division um
separate from the holocene in which we
are already living
okay so perhaps i better stop now and
let bruce have it
okay before before you start bruce let
me just remind uh our viewers that if
you want to ask questions of our guests
um please
scroll down to
near the bottom of your screen or the
middle of your screen and add your
questions to the comment page i will see
that
on my trusty little ipad which is
sitting right next to the screen here
we've got one comment but i'm hoping
that we'll get a number more um before
the day is done so that's the way to ask
your questions is to go down to that
comment page um
we're trying something new here the last
several weeks with these video chats so
none of us are completely used to it
we're all kind of on a learning curve
and that's probably is true of the
viewers too but we do really uh welcome
your comments and want to make sure that
you get your input into this
so bruce uh you've heard with what
philip had to say
um in terms of reasons why he thinks
that um
perhaps this is not the appropriate
thing to do and we'll go back to the
question of how likely it is that there
really will be an anthropocene in a
moment but
um you and i were both in honolulu just
a couple of weeks ago we weren't there
to sit on the beach but we were there
for the society of american archaeology
meetings
and um we both attended a panel you as a
panel member and me as journalist in the
audience
on archaeological perspectives in on the
anthropocene and during that panel
uh which is
the link to my story on that is down on
the chat page too below the readers can
have access to that
um
you took the position not only that we
should be designating the anthropocene
but you and your co-author on your
presentation
uh mindy zeeter your colleague there at
the museum
but that we should actually start it
with the origins of agriculture which
would pretty much put it to the
beginning of the holocene
um as you and others pointed out this
would make the holocene and the
anthropocene run together
at the same time
i
and
so let me ask you two things um one is
tell us why you think that the
anthropocene should start with the
origins of agriculture in other words
almost you know at least 11 000 years
ago
and
what about this problem of having the
holocene and the anthropocene be
basically the same time period how do we
get around that
okay i was fascinated by phil's uh
response to your question in that my
colleague mindy zeder and i coming at it
from a very different perspective
came up with almost exactly the same
position in the end
and that is we we argue in a paper
the paper we gave at the saa meetings
and which will be coming out in the new
journal anthropocene
uh number one that uh
we need to think of the anthropocene in
terms of its practical if we use it as a
as an epoch
we need to think of it in terms of its
utility or practical value
in the same way that phil talked about
the holocene being defined in terms of
its utility and practical value when in
fact it was just
another interglacial period within the
plasticine
and secondly if you start if you look at
it begin from that perspective and then
you think about not so much looking for
the
change in greenhouse gases
evidence or markers or of different
people arguing when the anthropocene
starts
and there are lots of different markers
that have been identified
pollen records 13 800 years ago
anthropogenic soils 2 000 years ago
methane and co2 5 to 8 000 years ago the
industrial revolution ad 1750 and more
recently
nuclear bomb fallout all these different
markers all of these different proposed
onsets of the anthropocene
a real practical solution
to that would be to have it co-evil with
the whole scene that gets rid of the
whole issue of
what kind whether or not it qualifies
for ethical status with the uh
with the geologists
and also we would argue that if you're
looking for golden spikes or markers you
can find them in the archaeological
record
right at the end of the or the beginning
of the holocene 11 000 nine thousand
years ago they occur in the
archaeological record and the other
thing we suggest is that rather than
looking at results you look at causes
you look at the first appearance
of human development of the ability to
substantially modify environments
and if you look over the last 10 000
years
not just at changes in atmospheric
greenhouse gases but at the ways in
which humans have modified the
terrestrial landscape of the earth it's
essentially at least up until the
industrial revolution and particularly
up until the second world war it's
almost entirely a result of the
expansion of agricultural landscapes
clearing of trees the development of
livestock herds that produce methane and
then if you look in the archaeological
record particularly given all the new
research that's been done over the last
15 years
you look for the first evidence of
domesticates in different parts of the
world and it's domesticated plants and
animals that are the basis for
agriculture if you look for them they
appear in the far east in the near east
in south america and in mexico all at
the same time individual
domestication events by independent
populations of a wide variety of
different species of plants and animals
all at about the same time and it's also
matches or fits one of the other
hard rock criteria that people deal with
in looking at extinctions and that you
could argue it is in fact the appearance
of new species
as opposed to the disappearance of some
species
so we think there are some good if you
want to make the hard rock argument
there is a hard rock argument at least
in the archaeological record for uh
the
drawing the boundary and then
most archaeologists don't really
i think the anthropocene 2 has two parts
to it at least over the last 13 years
one is the the idea that if
if geologists identified or declared a
new epic called the anthropocene then it
would be sort of notarized as something
that is happening and and the
public around the world would would uh
take uh take note of it and i'm not sure
that's happened outside of the media and
some pundits i think maybe
climate science fiction clysei
novels might be a better way to get at
the general public with the idea of
we're doing horrible things to the earth
rather than declaring a new
geological epoch certainly right-wing
republicans are not going to be swayed
if uh
geologists declare a new geological
epoch
so to us and to most archaeologists we
would like the utility value of it even
if it's informally declared simply
because it may
draw more attention to
all of the archaeologists who are very
interested in looking at all the
different ways in which human societies
have modified environments over the last
10 000 years
now just in closing you can go back
before 10 000 years ago and find
evidence of human modification of
environments in lots of different ways
particularly burning of forests to
increase certain kinds of vegetation so
we're not arguing that there isn't any
modification of environments by humans
earlier than that but it is the
appearance of domesticates that mark the
development of a significant ability to
modify environments even though it's
another thousand years or so before or
more before agriculture really starts to
take off so if you look at the causes
rather than effects we think you could
make a pretty good argument
okay now on
this might be sort of the appropriate
moment to go to some of the comments and
the first very first comment i'm seeing
on my screen um actually might allow us
and and perhaps uh phillip um
in particular to
sort of segue on from what bruce just
said so i we've got a fairly provocative
comment here for our first one it's from
stevor
and it says i'm sure that being able to
claim we're in a new age makes these
experts experts in quotation marks i'm
afraid uh giddy at the thought of it
maybe there's some grant money available
to research it well that strikes me as a
pretty cynical comment but let me try to
rephrase it in a more constructive way
and that is
uh
is this and maybe i'll direct the
question to you first philip i there is
this working group on the anthropocene
but you know to what extent
is the anthropocene kind of
a public relations device to
uh
you know to sort of
counter climate change denialism as as
bruce alluded to
and to what extent is it
based on real science now you're sitting
there on the uh in the working group
with a lot of illustrious people in
addition to yourself
um
what i
do you know how could you describe sort
of the level of scientific
validity to this at least to sort of the
arguments and despite your own position
uh
what do you how do you think things are
going can you kind of give us a little
bit of a glimpse as to what we might
expect in 2016 are we going to have the
anthropocene or not which way are things
leaning if you can tell us that or if
you're allowed to
i'm likely to be biased i apologize
about this very right from the beginning
um
well i think i think bruce raised some
very important points and so of you uh
michael i think this uh
question of the ter the you know the the
the arrival of this term
out of the blue as it were uh has uh
um
been a very useful device because
whether or not we
like to
you know define it as a formal unit uh
it's still very useful in the sense that
it makes us think about
uh this whole issue and one of the
things which uh
well when i was president of the of the
uh
the quaternary stratigraphy commission
subcommission i instituted this uh this
anthropocene working group uh because uh
um you know it seems to me that this is
something we should be investigating
from a geological perspective um and
there is no doubt and i'm sure many of i
could sort of hear my geological
colleagues um you know in my head
telling
me that there's no doubt that that as
we've heard me you know human systems uh
humans sorry i have influenced natural
whoops i think we might have lost phil
there
oh now you're back good
sorry don't you lose me there uh we lost
you for just a second but go on ahead
because you're about you seem to be back
now okay
okay great um the um
uh
um
sorry i lost what i was saying
the critical point is that there's no
doubt that the humans i don't wish to
give it the impression that i give you
the impression that i i
i have any uh doubt that humans are
modifying the landscape and modifying
natural systems um you know in many many
ways that's beyond doubt the question of
course from a geological perspective is
is are we actually have we actually left
what could be called the natural
holocene and moved into a new a new um
period of time however we define it and
of course the original definition was
said to be the
the industrial revolution the arrival of
of human uh activity um which was
causing in you know industrial
development and therefore pollution and
and um increasing sedimentation
increasing gases and all that sort of
thing
my geological colleagues on the on the
panel many of whom think that this is um
that they would the this is justified to
to to uh define a new division on the
basis of that kind of evidence um would
point to the fact that if we are going
to identify an event which is discreet
from the um which can be differentiated
from the holocene that there are you
know we have to be able to recognize
these changes in uh
natural sedimentation systems
geologically in other words all over the
surface of the planet and uh
um
there is no doubt that this is going on
but the question of course in from a
from a geological geologist's
perspective is
whether
whether we have actually left the
holocene
and
um
bruce
mentioned that that he would like to see
um domestication or something similar um
used as a criterion for identification
of the anthropocene
our problem as geologists is that the
holocene was only divided only formally
defined about uh three years ago and
that basis of uh it's already been used
in it for a very long time but it was
formally defined and ratified by the
international union of geological
sciences only about three years ago um
and that means we can't just turn around
and change it there are certain legal uh
requirements which have to be met and uh
those uh then manager is not a simple
you know thing that we can just change
like you might change um the model of
car you drive or something like that you
know you've got to we've got we are but
there's a 10-year moratorium on
terminology and and there also has to be
a a a series of votes at various levels
within the
strategic commission and then uh final
ratification by the international union
of geological sciences if we are to
change uh the names of
of geological time units so we're not in
a position where we can just turn around
and say okay that's fine and uh you know
we'll just change it tomorrow and the
other the other thing is that i i can't
really see the need for the term
anthropocene if we're going to define it
as far back as 11 700 years ago because
we already have the holocene so you know
in the end this just becomes a label and
do we really just want to change the
label um you know but we're still having
the same period it's what my father used
to say is the same meat different gravy
you know i i hope your viewers will
understand that one but uh basically uh
you know as as human beings we modify
our environment all the time it's
typical of humans and
as again bruce mentioned you know uh
aborigines were already modifying their
environment 40 000 years ago in
australia when they arrived and they're
responsible of course for
or they are thought to be responsible
for the death of a number of
of the larger uh
animal uh taxa in in in australia so you
know where do you draw this line where
is the point and if you if you say okay
domestication yeah i'm happy to go with
that that would be fine but but uh you
know others would argue we should be
using uh
features such as the atom bomb uh
testing which gives us a global signal
and we we need a global signal for this
it's not just something we can recognize
you know one point in western europe
another point in southern africa if
we're going to define a boundary for a
geological purpose it has to be the same
time everywhere in the world and uh
that's a difficult tall order when it
comes to the uh you know the development
of of of human activity because it's
very different time in different places
um
so
i think i've gone off your question but
i hope that answers the point you know
but uh i i think i think
everything that you had to say was
extremely interesting and relevant um
let me go to another question from the
viewers this one comes from earl ellis
and maybe this is one that bruce we
could start off with you trying to
tackle
in terms of early human activity earl s
what is the role of early anthropogenic
fire in transforming the biosphere in
other words fire that humans sat rather
than natural fires um to what extent did
we begin changing uh or potentially
changing
um
the atmosphere really early on through
fire and of course as as we all know
there's been a lot of debates about just
when humans first uh
tamed fire or controlled it perhaps is
the better word so how would you respond
to that question bruce oh okay just to
start off to
to respond to what phil said uh what we
were proposing actually uh you won't
find many archaeologists who are really
uh eager supporters or proponents of the
establishment of the anthropocene
at any point in time i don't think even
back coevo with the
with the holocene the reason
we were proposing it at the at the
beginning of the hall scene and what we
what we suggested was that perhaps you
could keep the holocene as
the term uh for that time period in
scientific discourse and define or
identify or characterize the
anthropocene as a term that might be
used in more popular discourse and just
sort of
finesse or deflect the whole issue of
when the anthropocene may start if in
fact it does exist by arguing that
archaeologists and a lot of
archaeologists uh spend their whole
careers looking at the extent to which
in the ways in which humans have
modified environments uh particularly uh
since the end of the pleistocene so
we're not we're not proposing that the
holocene be junked or that the
anthropocene uh take its place just that
they if you're gonna have an
anthropocene it ought to be co-evil in
some way formal or informal with the
holocene and that just gets rid of the
whole issue of of whether or not you
need a geological golden spike to define
the beginning of the anthropocene and
there are a lot of people or some people
at least that are arguing that if you
are going to define or look for the
onset of the anthropocene you have to
look for criteria or markers that are
beyond stratigraphic global
signatures and that human activities
just are beyond the pale in that regard
which we think is another good reason to
just try to
go with the beginning of the hall scene
in terms of fire being used as a
modifier of environments it's
it's probably the most commonly uh
identified archaeological marker of
human uh modification of ecosystems or
ecosystem engineering or niche
construction
it's difficult to identify in the
archaeological record we have a huge
literature on ethnographic accounts of
burning of grasslands and also forested
areas to
modify environments more to the liking
of the small-scale human societies that
are doing it there's actually a
wonderful article that just came out in
the last couple of years by
bird and bleachbird in pnas on
their recent 12 years of research on
looking at australian aboriginal groups
of burning of grasslands and how it
actually
increases the biomass of one of their
primary uh prey species
but when you get into the archaeological
record it's difficult to separate out
human burning from natural forest fires
it is theoretically possible to do it by
looking
human burns are usually
small and well controlled which produce
smaller
sized charcoal fragments and
uncontrolled forest fires over large
areas tend to produce larger
uh forest uh charcoal fragments but it's
still a difficult thing to do
uh phil mentioned earlier probably uh
there's been some good evidence that uh
in southeast asian forests of burning
deliberate human burning of forests
going back at least 40 000 years
and it could go back uh certainly
earlier than that
but it's sort of difficult to establish
okay
now uh on some of these issues that
we've been discussing especially that
phil has raised it's an interesting
question from kim
um and by the way uh viewers you have to
forgive us if we can't get to all of
your questions but you can put questions
down under the comments page and even if
our guests are not able to get to your
questions other people looking at the
archive page will see them so you can
sort of have input into this even if we
can't get specifically to the question
you're asking
but kim asked um
will the holocene be measurable
geologically in the far future if it
ends after a mere 10 000 years
and that strikes me as a good question
if we if we don't destroy the planet in
a million years from now we've got
geologists and archaeologists still
working
um at our major universities and
elsewhere
uh
then i
and if the holocene is only going to be
about 11 000 years old or something like
that
um
and the pleistocene lasted between 1.8
million and that 11
hundred and then before that the plea
scene was more than three million years
and then before that the myocene was
what some 20 million years if i'm if i'm
remembering my epochs right
um
i think what kim is asking is won't the
holocene just be kind of a blip in
geological time a million years from now
if we end it so soon don't we want it to
kind of hang around a little bit longer
before we dispatch with it
thanks for that
you know i mean are there going to be
any geologists around in the future well
i have no idea but of course we are the
sort of the earth so i imagine um anyway
the archaeologists will be too i suspect
you um
yeah it's a good point that the holocene
is 11 000 11 and a half thousand years
long yes um and uh it is just a blip
really and uh geologically um many
people many of the more serious
geologists i perhaps could use the term
sirius
uh would consider that the whole
quaternary is merely a blip
but of course if we think about uh
geological time um the nearer we get to
the present day and
the more that we're involved and by we i
mean you know
homospa
is involved the more important it
becomes for us so i guess it's a kind of
logarithmic scale
um the last interglacial period
which was uh about 125 000 years ago
um
was
has been
shown to be
about 12 000 years long
and we can still find that in the
geological record
and in fact a great deal of work has
been done on it
earlier interglacials are similar length
some of them a little bit longer some of
them a little bit shorter and we can
certainly find them
and uh have they've been studied in
great detail in some parts of the world
uh and in many different environments
so uh to answer
the question of the future i think uh
yes we should find the holocene and more
importantly of course from an
anthropogenic
um
perspective
um we will not only find uh the sort of
natural evidence for human activity but
all the sort of materials and uh and
junk that we've left behind like old
bottles and
you know beer cans and
supermarket trolleys and uh all the
other things that go up to make our uh
our uh
um environment that we've created
ourselves these will be preserved some
of them at least in
natural systems and i imagine um the
geologists of the future will be very
pleased to find them because then they
can use them as very clear time markers
um
the this has been suggested in uh by one
geologist who who who was quite i think
partially joking but suggested that in
alaska it would be possible to use uh
beer bottles as a means of identifying
um last interglacial deposits uh
disintegration deposits sorry last
decade last century's deposits um in
river valleys because the the bottles
are still preserved in the gravels etc
that's rather a flipping answer but i
hope it's
some way to just to to follow on to what
phil said uh on the one hand we're i
don't think we're gonna have a natural
end point for the whole scene and that
we're never gonna have another ice age
i don't agree
and secondly the holocene is going to
have to end soon because we're already
in the late hall scene
phil that sounds like one for you now
are humans pumping so much co2 and
heating the planet so much that
we we're just never going to have an ice
age again or
i are we really still fairly puny in the
uh
against the forces of nature as a whole
well i think that's a that's something
that people have given a lot of thought
to and uh
clearly uh our activities are not going
to uh go unnoticed as it were um most uh
people if you if you if you said that
if if activities of humans hadn't uh
taken place we are just about due to go
back into the next cold period and uh i
remember when i was uh relatively young
um seeing programs on television saying
that we're about to enter the next ice
age and that was before the the the
enormity of the climate impact of what
we're up to
um
became apparent however uh some quite a
lot of modelling has been done on this
issue and it's clear that that uh the
carbon the fossil carbon and other such
materials that we've released into the
atmosphere um is definitely going to um
uh influence the climate systems but uh
eventually the earth will restore uh the
balance and once this carbon the carbon
material a carbon dioxide cut in the
form of carbonate or
organic materials it goes back into
storage once again
then i think uh we will go back uh and
the and the earth will continue its uh
um
uh
ice age
uh climate pattern because the climate
pattern of the uh you know we haven't we
may have changed the the the atmospheric
composition in on a temporary basis but
in in the long term um
it's going to the earth is going to
restore the natural balance and we will
go back into into the city into a normal
rhythm of change while the while the the
earth is in its present uh the the
distribution of land
the um you know so
uh impact of solar heating etc remains
basically the same and that's uh changes
in the planetary orbits etc
okay
um
bruce did you have anything where you
wanted to say on that or
nope
okay
now i
here's a question um
let me just uh find that again here yes
this is from out laymen or outlay man
we'll have to ask out layman how he or
she wants their name to be pronounced
their handle but um the question is what
are the practical implications of these
decisions in 2016 apart from changes in
the textbooks and how binding they could
be
and then out layman refers to evolution
versus
evolutionism versus creationism
um
that strikes me as kind of an
interesting question um
phil i don't want to put you on the spot
here but
i i did uh ask you uh what you thought
the likelihood was that in 2016 we're
going to really have an anthropocene
where uh
you know where the forces i
by the way
on that point just to interrupt myself
um one of the points that the
archaeologists at the panel in honolulu
made
was that there aren't any archaeologists
or anthropologists on the panel and um
in an email exchange that you and i had
you said that you thought that that
discipline or those disciplines should
have some input into these kinds of
decisions
so um
we don't need to get into sort of the
ins and outs of how that panel was
chosen necessarily
but how likely is it a that uh sort of
that broader input might come to play
you know
perspectives like bruce's and other
archaeologists who may not think it
should start with the beginning of the
holocene but think maybe it should start
even earlier with mega final extinctions
back as early as 40 000 years ago to
what extent are those kinds of
considerations uh
coming into play in the activities of
the working group
and
once again
do you have any sort of predictions for
us as to what is likely to happen and if
you want to duck that question i won't
ask it again but i'm going to try one
last time i'm a journalist after all and
that's my job okay
i i don't want to hog this discussion
though i mean you know anyway i think
bruce is getting his licks in pretty
well
well i i'm not so sure that you
shouldn't but can i just say right from
the beginning the this this working
group was not set up to define the ant
prophecy
okay
this working group was set up
to examine the possibility of
an anthropocene division
so there's no certain outcome that will
from from this commission the commission
is the commission is looking at the
possibility it's not looking to define
uh to formally define uh um
a boundary necessarily there's a it's
it's it's doing this work to determine
whether whether we we should or and
could define such a boundary and if that
boundary if if they can find such a
boundary and if people can agree on a
boundary then uh it has to go forward
and it has to be voted on as i've said
um at a series of different levels
starting with the quaternary group uh
the quaternary subcommission
then it has to go to the uh
international commission on stratigraphy
which is made up of geologists from
throughout the um
throughout the geological time period
from the beginning of time actually
and uh
and then and and then and only then if
it's approved by a super majority of
over 60 percent of the voting members
will it go forward for ratification so
that's the formal structure of of this
uh
of this um
proposal and of the working groups
activity um whether i think you'll be
defined or not well i i am quite
skeptical actually um but i think the
point that bruce made is actually a
really good one and that would be that's
a compromise that i've only recently
heard said and uh and i think it's
it would it would work rather well um
but i i think the problem is for
geologists is this is this is this name
actually the anthropocene
because it makes us think of pleistocene
holocene oligocene eocene all the
divisions of the last um
uh well
60 million years ending scene which
means life and of course it's this is
the cenozoic of a canoza if you prefer
that pronunciation
which is characterized by mammals and
flowering plants um and that means us
too of course and uh uh by using the
this this suffix scene um it suggests um
a period of equivalent status to
holocene and uh pleistocene and for us
that is not likely to be accepted
because um
for us there isn't sufficient difference
even taking into account all the things
we've discussed already to see today um
uh between the holocene and the period
now both periods are characterized by
very
by the presence of humans by the pre by
the presence of uh similar vegetation
and um um
and faunal elements so it's it's i think
it's unlikely that the the that this
this term anthropocene would be defined
at as the same status as holostein if we
if it were defined geologically and that
doesn't mean to say the term can't be
used informally and i think in in brut
bruce has suggested that would be a
really
much more sensible solution in this case
because
um
if it's to run especially if it's to run
from the from eleven thousand seven
hundred years ago as he uh as bruce said
it would run in parallel with the
holocene um but for geologists we have
and we our task is simply to to to
provide nomenclature for geologists
and if
but if there's a general popular
movement to use the term anthropocene
for this period uh that wouldn't be a
problem for us and in fact it wouldn't
even be our business actually
does that answer the question i think so
um did you have anything you wanted to
add to that
uh
just that uh archaeologists uh of course
uh work within the uh
geological time frame and we use early
middle and late hall scene all the time
we're sort of freed from stratigraphic
uh requirements and that we can use
radiocarbon dating and we work a lot
with
absolute dates rather than
talking about the early late middle hall
scene but we do
we are overburdened still with lots of
terminological
uh frameworks for time like the
epi-paleolithic and the pre-pottery
neolithic a and b so we deal with those
problems too uh but i don't think it
would
bother archaeologists very much if
anthropocene wasn't uh
the absence of the the term and the
concept and the epoch of the
anthropocene has not hindered
archaeologists in doing their work at
all the the only concern i would have is
that if
actually if you extended the the use
of or the application of the term
anthropocene back to 10 000 years ago
some people might then say oh well if
humans have been a significant force in
modifying the earth for 10 000 years you
know it's the same old
game we've been doing it we'll continue
to do it and there's no problem
okay are either of you guys worried that
if the anthropocene is not officially
designated in 2016
that that will give ammunition to
climate denied climate change denials
they will say our scientific bodies got
together and they said that humans
really are not having
enough of a chain effect on the
environment to give us a whole new age
the age of man any concerns about that
this goes back to some of the pr
questions the pr
aspects of this whole thing
that's a great question we can all point
our fingers at the geologist and say way
to go
well
actually michael can i just say that i
should have said that that as i as
indeed you alluded to when you spoke to
me
uh when we talked about the email uh
discussion we had i've uh we i felt very
it's very important to have
archaeologists on
on this panel
you know especially if on the working
group as it were
because they had been left out and that
was seem to me very important because we
have to think about i think that what's
more interesting here is not whether we
whether whether the whether we define
anthropocene and and whether it you know
people use this as ammunition to uh to
pretend that the climate
kind of isn't going to be influenced by
the activities of humans i should think
that's already pretty obvious when
you've seen the weather that we've been
having for the last few uh decades or so
but i mean um
the the the
the critical point here is is is how we
classify time and you know the trouble
for geologists is as we get to the
present day we're kind of segueing into
archaeological time and then historical
time of that is to say human time and we
have to find a kind of um
means of develop defining uh the
divisions of time which which fit all
fits together as far as we can and maybe
we're not going to achieve that
completely but i think it's very uh you
know as bruce says that it's very
important that we that we provide um
uh time divisions which we which we can
work with i mean that's the test
are these divisions useful or not and if
they're not useful we don't want them if
they are useful and i think it's very
important
that this is you know that that
the all the communities are that are
using this these divisions are brought
together um
then then we have to find a you know
a time division which we can all time
division scheme which we can all work
with
okay
now um i think we'll go to one last
question and um this is actually uh i'm
going to interpret this as a little bit
more of a comment than a question and it
probably goes over some of the ground
that both of you have already um
covered
but i think it's put in a very
interesting way and there's a question i
see in in this comment this is from
woman
okay we have great very colorful
uh handles here on uh among our
commentators uh out laymen and sledge
woman and and lots of others
so
sledge woman assuming that this is a she
she says isn't the real value of the
term anthropocene that it draws
attention to the role humans play in
modifying shaping and ultimately driving
earth systems natural and biological so
rather than worrying about drawing
boundaries and defining an onset point
for the anthropocene wouldn't it be more
productive to focus on
tracking the changing nature of human
and environmental interaction over time
shouldn't we be looking for evidence of
when and how the balance shifted from
humans being a part of earth systems to
being major dominant drivers of these
systems rather than arguing about
nomenclature and golden spikes that
seems to be pretty eloquently put but uh
let me boil that whole comment down
um into one question uh
if that's fair to sledge woman and that
is
i is the concept of the anthropocene and
the banding about and considering this
as a possible new epic
stimulating research into the very
questions that sledge woman is talking
about in other words is it having a
positive effect of our needing to take a
closer look at just exactly what the
parameters of human activity are on the
planet
i'll throw that out to either one of you
whoever wants to start i think it is i
think that one of the things that uh um
my colleague mindy zeder and i were
fascinated by was going through the
literature of all the different
proposed onset points for the
anthropocene and
finding the extent to which there were
all these different kinds of markers at
different points in time
marking different ways in which human
societies were modifying either
climate or environment or terrestrial
ecosystems so it is
it does
spur people's interest in looking at
different kinds of
human impacts on the environment over
last 10 000 or more years
okay
and phil sort of a final comment on that
issue yeah do i agree entirely and i
mean i think that that's that's
absolutely uh a vital point you know i
mean quaternary workers and i'm a
quaternary worker have have been for a
long time um you know and that's the
beauty of this quaternary is that it
sort of
involves
uh people such as bruce you know and the
archaeological community but also
botanist zoologists climatologists
oceanographers i mean this this
community has been very aware of of of
uh the impact of of humans and uh the
impact of of
climate and the interaction of these
things together with all the other
changes which are going on on the
surface of the earth and i think i think
the uh the um
activities of of humans and the impact
on natural systems is is a very is an
excellent uh
uh stimulus really to to research and i
think that this will i mean you asked
earlier about
whether this would you know could be
something that people would go towards
to uh uh get to grant grant money for
research well yes it will and then
people have done already and are doing
so already what i think has been
exciting for me to see was is that a
number of a number of things have
occurred already and such we now have a
new journal which uh our friends in the
netherlands have uh have have started to
publish on on the anthropocene and this
will obviously uh encourage research
into the into this topic and uh um
and indeed a number of books already
have started to appear so uh i i you
know i think this is terrific and this
this is uh
you know we shouldn't get bogged down as
as as your correspondent said uh in in
in boundary definition that's just where
i've come at this thing from but i i in
as a as a geologist interested in the
evolution of a natural environment well
yes
of course i can see that this is a
really positive development and then it
should be encouraged that people look at
this sort of thing
okay well listen we're just about out of
time i want to thank both of you very
much for participating um i found it uh
extremely interesting and i've got no
doubt that our viewers did as well i
apologize if we were not able to get to
all of your questions but we covered
quite a few of them and there always are
duplications um
and and questions that uh i sort of uh
in my role as host deemed to be
irrelevant but most of the questions
were very relevant and very good just
two last things one is is that i'd like
to remind everybody that next week's
chat we do this every week believe it or
not we're gonna have a discussion not me
but one of my colleagues will host it a
discussion of the h7
uh rather h7n9 bird flu
and how it might impact people and water
scientists learning about how it's
transmitted and how to stop it and
finally um and i know phil you and i
discussed this article and uh obviously
it's very pro uh naming the anthropocene
but i'm going to if if i do the
technical uh things right here as i was
taught i'm going to put up on the screen
as kind of the final shot here um
a
screen image of a paper that was
published in 2011 in the philosophical
transactions of the royal society a
this was a a paper called the
anthropocene conceptual and historical
perspectives by will steffen in
australia and the authors include paul
crewson who was the nobel laureate who
was one of the original proponents of uh
naming the anthropocene so just before
we go here i'm going to put that up on
the screen it is available uh
open access online
uh and i'll do that just before our
technical people shut us down here and
put us into the archives and make us
part of either holocene or anthropocene
uh history or records so thank you both
gentlemen very much
i and we'll see you out there uh in
whatever epic we happen to be everybody
and here comes that
screenshot if i can do this
right
here we go
and let's see
just bear with me i'm having just some
slight technical problems uh due to my
macbook not being perfect but uh there
we go okay if all go if all went well
you should be seeing a screenshot of
this paper
in the philosophical transactions of the
royal society a
uh i'll just scroll down and you can
kind of see the abstract
um
it's very interesting it's a very
detailed sort of review
of human interactions with the planet
and effects on the environment together
with the strong argument for why the
anthropocene should begin around the
time of the industrial revolution
and not at early periods and this is
available
by open access online
okay goodbye everybody